as of April 29th 2020 the Federal
Reserve has injected 2.3 trillion
dollars in order to fund stimulus checks
to businesses households hospitals local
governments and so on and so forth
this has elected a Fed holding a record
six point six trillion dollars in assets
and analysts suggest that this number
could reach 10 trillion dollars in just
the next few months of course this is a
required step in order to ease a
negative economic impact that the recent
situation has brought forth but when
everything is said and done what will be
the long-term repercussions of all of
the stimulus
[Music]
well starting off to answer that
question we have to first take a look at
where this money is even coming from
first the US Treasury will attempt to
sell I are used to basically anyone who
is interested this could be banks
companies or you buying IOUs from the US
government is seen as essentially a
no-risk investment as it is backed by
the federal government
however selling these IOUs will not be
enough to pay out the enormous stimulus
checks promised especially when there
are less buyers in the market for these
IOUs
as many businesses and citizens are
struggling to survive financially to
make up the deficit the Fed engages in
what is known as quantitative easing in
this scenario instead of the Treasury
sign that I are used to the public it
will solve these values to the Federal
Reserve and the Federal Reserve will
just print this money in order to pay
the Treasury actually nowadays they
literally just digitally add the money
into your bank accounts to pay them if
you have ever watched a show money heist
quantitative easing is precisely what
their target if the government can
simply print trillions a lot of which is
spent and efficiently it's not that big
of a deal for a few robbers to print a
couple billion anyways what does
artificially creating all this money do
starting with the positives they're
quite obvious this money will help
thousands of businesses survive millions
of people to keep their jobs and help
millions to simply carry out daily life
as for the negatives the first concern
that comes to mind is inflation money is
just like any other product and having
trillions more in circulation will
increase the supply of money while the
demand stays constant basic economics
will tell you that this would lead to US
currency decrease in value or
essentially inflation but this is
actually not true the thing is the
amount of money in circulation is just
one factor there are six main factors
that lead to inflation which are cuts in
interest rates increase in money supply
higher wages devaluation increase in
value added tax and inflation
expectations the Federal Reserve has
been cutting interest rates and
increasing the money supply so these two
factors will be contributing to
inflation
but ask for higher wages while 30
million Americans have just filed for
employment
so wages aren't going up anytime soon so
if anything wages will stay stagnant ask
for devaluation this is the phenomenon
in which imported goods rise and prior
to due to increased domestic demand
people are going to be much more
cautious when buying things moving
forward so devaluation is not going to
be a threat
moving onto value-added taxes the
government is trying to submit the
economy by offering incentives so it is
highly unlikely that we see any
increases in any taxes right now and
finally we have expectations of
inflation this is when workers expect
your wages to increase with inflation
but many people who currently have a job
are simply happy to have a job and there
are millions unemployed so I doubt most
people are expecting their wages to be
increasing considering all of this only
two factors of supporting inflation
while four factors are opposing it
furthermore cutting interest rates and
increase money supply are some of the
less influential factors on top of this
the value of a currency is also
dependent on the foreign exchange market
in other words occurences value is also
dependent on how other currencies are
doing and the thing is virtually all
countries are injecting money and
offering a variety of stimulus packages
so when everyone is injecting money its
impact our inflation is further reduced
as a result money injections will
actually not cause inflation they were
actually hoping to prevent deflation
which is the real threat during
recessions taking a look at the historic
inflation rate of the US you will see
that a negative inflation rate or
deflation accompanies every recession so
stimulus checks are beneficial to
inflation rate as well but there is one
large negative impact which is increased
national debt the national debt of most
countries were already at all-time highs
the number actually doesn't matter but
what does matter is that the debt to GDP
ratios were also at all-time highs and
governments have been forced to spend
even more given the current situation
however this spending will not be enough
to prevent the GDP of countries from
falling while also increasing national
debt
so over the next few years stimulus
plans will lead to an increase in the
debt to GDP ratios for most countries
unfortunately we have no effective way
to prevent this from happening and
currently the national debt is not the
most pressing issue in fact in April a
survey found that 88 percent of
Americans believe that the stimulus plan
was a right thing to do and only 1%
thought that the national debt was the
most pressing issue overall the stimulus
plan has led to large money injections
which are actually not that big of deal
economically that there are many other
factors playing on inflation and this
money is essential to at least somewhat
maintain national GDP s however over the
long term this will lead to higher debt
to GDP ratios which we will eventually
have to deal with but given the current
situation injecting more money though
not the most efficient is the best
choice not only economically but also
morally if you guys thought this video
provided an in-depth analysis of the
economic impact of stimulus checks that
makes you drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one